[Musique]
je vais commencer par vous raconter une
petite anecdote familiale chez moi au
petit déjeuner on prend des céréales
alors il ya mes enfants de 12 et 15 ans
qui prennent le paquet de céréales et
qui remplissent totalement le bol
jusqu'en haut
et il en laisse la moitié une fois sur
deux puis de l'autre côté il ya moi qui
essaient de maintenir un semblant de
ligne et qu'ils essayent du coup de s'en
tenir aux 45 g recommandé au dos du
paquet par le fabricant alors est-ce que
vous avez déjà pesé 45 grammes de
céréales
est-ce que vous avez une idée de ce que
ça fait alors j'ai pris une photo pour
vous voilà ce que donne 45 grammes de
céréales à l'intérieur d'un bol alors
j'ai usé tous les arguments possibles
d'un côté pour essayer de convaincre mes
enfants d' arrêter de gâcher la
nourriture est donc tout simplement de
remplir le bol à moitié kita se
resservir s'il en voulait et ils sont
tout à fait d'accord avec moi ils
avaient parfaitement envie de le faire
hein oui oui papa on va remplir à moitié
et puis moi d'un autre côté qui
déprimait devant mon bol de céréales à
peu près à moitié vide alors à court
d'arguments face à mes enfants et face à
ma volonté
qu'est ce que j'ai fait eh ben j'ai
acheté de nouveaux vols j'ai acheté les
bols plus petit et avec ses modes multi
mes enfants continuent à remplir le bol
à ras bord sauf que cette fois-ci
n'engage plus du tout puisqu'il en
maintenant à l'intérieur et moi ben
finalement je suis beaucoup moins
déprimés devant un petit bol plein que
devant un grand bol vide alors pour pas
grand chose finalement l'achat de
quelques bols j'ai réussi à faire
changer de comportement mes enfants et
moi dans la joie et dans la bonne humeur
est ce que j'ai fait là sa porte un nom
ça s'appelle le nudge et le nudge c'est
une passion que j'ai découvert il ya
quelques temps et que j'avais envie de
partager avec vous ce soir le note jean
français ça veut dire coup de pouce
incitations douce
comment est ce qu'on peut faire des
petits changements à l'intérieur de
l'environnement pour changer de manière
très forte les comportements et pour
aider les gens qui ont une intention à
passer à l'action
alors pour bien comprendre ce que c'est
qu'un âge je vous propose de découvrir
l'exemple le plus célèbre de ns
cette mouche n'est pas une mouche c'est
un âge c'est un autocollant et ça
devient un âge quand on le colle au bon
endroit et le bon endroit
désolé mesdames c'est au fond de
l'urinoir des toilettes des hommes
pourquoi ce stickers de uche devient
oeuvre quand on le colle au fond des
toilettes des hommes mais parce que
l'homme est un grand enfant et que quand
ils voient une mouche au fond des
toilettes qu'est ce qu'il fait il vise
la mouche et en visant la mouche il ne
vise plus à côté et comme il ne vise
plus à côté dans l'aéroport d'amsterdam
là où ils ont collé cette mouche dans
les toilettes ç'a eu pour impact
d'économiser 80 % des dépenses de
nettoyage
alors j'aime beaucoup cet exemple
d'abord parce qu'en règle générale il a
pour pour vertu de briser un petit peu
la glace et puis la vraie raison dans
laquelle je laime c'est qu'ils reflètent
totalement l'esprit de ce que c'est que
le nudge on aurait pu chercher à vous
persuader de rendre cet endroit aussi
propre que vous aimeriez le trouver en
entrant ça ça s'appelle de l'information
on met des panneaux à l'entrée des
toilettes et il faut continuer à le
faire
c'est utile mais ça va juste vous donner
une indication et ça va pas forcément
vous amener à franchir le petit pas qui
va vous faire avoir
le comportement désiré avec le nudge
cherche plus à persuader les gens peu
importe qu'ils soient persuadés ou non
la seule chose qu'on cherche à faire
c'est de changer les comportements
pour les aider à passer d'une intention
à une action alors le nudge on va
pouvoir l'utiliser dans tous les cas où
on va être face à un besoin de
changement de comportement prenons
l'environnement par exemple nous sommes
61% selon les sondages à nous déclarer
très concerné par l'environnement
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait au quotidien
est-ce qu'on recycle suffisamment est ce
que on va économiser l'eau comme il le
faut est-ce qu'on va économiser
l'énergie comme il le faut voici une
photo d'une université à la nuit
tombante
qu'est-ce qui se passe toutes les salles
sont allumés alors comment est ce qu'on
peut faire pour inciter les étudiants à
ne pas laisser l'ensemble des salles
allumé quand ils s'en vont mais plutôt à
les éteindre
eh bien d'abord on va mettre une
information merci d'éteindre la lumière
et puis à côté qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va rajouter un edge ce match avec 80
% des étudiants de l'université
éteignent la lumière en quittant la
pièce et vous point d'interrogation
si on pose cette question là c'est 80 %
des gens le font humainement qu'est ce
que je vais avoir tendance à faire
exactement la même chose que c'est 80%
des jambes et au final en implémentant
se nage
qu'est ce qui va se passer 26% de
lumière reste est inutilement allumé en
moins alors vous allez me dire comment
de si petits détails peuvent avoir de si
grand impact sur le comportement il ya
forcément quelque chose derrière tout ça
n'est pas très rationnel et vous avez
raison
en fait la majeure partie des décisions
qu'on prend on les prend avec ce que
daniel kahneman daniel kahneman pardon
prix nobel d'économie en 2002 appelle le
système 1 le système 1 c'est la partie
de votre cerveau qui va décider de
manière intuitive rapide sans effort qui
va aller directement à la conclusion
voici un petit exemple à votre avis
quelle est la table qui est la plus
longue et la plus étroite
a priori vous voyez celle de gauche
correspond à ce que j'ai à vous dire
et ça c'est votre système qui vous le
dit la réalité et vous allez le voir
avec cette animation c'est que ces deux
tables font exactement la même longueur
et la même largeur réalisé sans trucage
et ce qui est impressionnant c'est que
je suis sûr que même maintenant vous le
savez que je voulais démontrer
vous continuez à voir la table de gauche
comme plus longue et plus étroite que la
table de droite c'est normal votre
système 1 est toujours en mode
automatique il est toujours en action
et si vous voulez effectivement être
totalement convaincu que ces deux tables
font exactement la même longueur et la
même largeur
il va falloir passer en système 2 le
système 2 c'est celui qui va vous
inviter à prendre à m est allé vérifier
que effectivement les côtés sont bien
donné la longueur est de même largeur
alors c'est daniel kahneman je vous
disais tout à l'heure prix nobel
d'économie 2002 qui a théorisé ces deux
vitesse de la pensée le système 1 d'un
côté rapide de systèmes deux de l'autre
côté plus lent et dans cette phrase
daniel kahneman a gagné a remporté le
prix nobel d'économie en 2002 il ya
quelque chose d'assez troublant ce qui
est troublant c'est que daniel kahneman
n'est pas du tout un économiste daniel
kahneman est un psychologue
alors pourquoi les économistes vont
donner un prix nobel a dit à un
psychologue a priori ça peut paraître
étonnant mais en fait ça n'est pas tant
que ça il ya vingt ans quand j'étais sur
les bancs de la fac en économie
mon professeur m'a appris que les agents
économiques c'est-à-dire vous tous et
moi y compris
nous prenons nos décisions en maximisant
notre utilité sous contrainte budgétaire
en ayant une information parfaite en
étant totalement capable de traiter
l'ensemble de cette information et en
ayant des préférences qui sont
totalement stable dans le temps j'ai eu
un petit malaise en fait quand j'ai
entendu ça parce que moi je ne me suis
pas sentie prendre toutes mes décisions
en maximisant mon utilité sous
contraintes budgétaires et une fois que
j'avais pris mes décisions
ben je n'étais pas non plus totalement
certain qu'elle soit suivie d'actions
par derrière
ça m'a tellement perturbé que j'ai fait
une thèse de doctorat sur le sujet pour
le passage de l'intention à l'action et
aujourd'hui j'en ai fait mon métier
j'essaye de comprendre comment les vrais
gens décident dans la vraie vie comment
effectivement il met en oeuvre ce qu'ils
ont envie de faire
alors si les économistes ont donné un
prix nobel
un psychologue vous voyez que c'est
parce qu'ils ont tout simplement compris
que finalement nous sommes aussi
peut-être juste des êtres humains avec
nos émotions avec nos habitudes avec une
influence de l'environnement physique
une influence de l'environnement social
qui va impacter nos décisions bref que
nous ressemblons peut-être un peu plus à
homer simpson cas superman alors
effectivement nous ne sommes pas très
rationnel mais c'est pas désespérant
pourquoi c'est pas désespérant parce
qu'une bonne nouvelle et la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ces comportements
irrationnels que nous avons on est
capable de les expliquer grâce à des
recherches en économie comportementale
en gros les comportements irrationnels
que nous avons ne sont pas aléatoires
ils sont pas insensé ils sont pas
absurde
en fait ils sont assez systématique et
même ils sont prévisibles en 50 ans de
recherche académique
les chercheurs en économie
comportementale ont identifié une
centaine de billets qui venait justement
expliqué pourquoi nos comportements
étaient irrationnelles par exemple le
biais d' ancrage le biais d' ancrage
c'est celui qui fait que mes enfants
mettent les céréales jusqu'en haut du
bol parce que finalement la taille du
bol constitue une ancre un point de
référence qui va déterminer la quantité
qu'on a envie de mettre dedans
après il ya le biais de gratification
c'est quand même assez plaisant d'avoir
réussi à viser juste sur cette satanée
mouche qui était au fond de l'urinoir et
puis il ya les normes sociales
celle qui fait que comme 80% des
étudiants
moi aussi je vais éteindre la lumière en
sortant de cette pièce alors la liste
des billets comme ça les longues je vais
pas la faire en totalité
mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a bien compris la
manière dont ces biais agissait eh ben
on va pouvoir agir dessus pour essayer
de changer les comportements et aider
les gens à passer d'une intention à une
action en fait chaque billet va être une
source d'inspiration pour construire un
âge
prenons un exemple
vous mettez une quarantaine de films à
l'intérieur d'une butte d'une pièce sur
la table parmi ces 40 films il va y en
avoir certains qui vont être dit de type
vis comme ici batman un bon film
d'action un blockbuster américain sur
lequel on va pas cramé trop de neurones
et puis vous avez d'autres films qui
vont être catalogué de type vertu par
exemple ici
dix artistes sur lequel bah oui on va
passer un bon moment mais peut-être
qu'il va falloir marcher un peu faire
marcher un petit peu plus le cerveau et
faire un petit peu plus d'efforts on va
demander aux gens de choisir ses films
selon trois possibilités on va leur
demander de choisir trois films mais on
va leur demander de choisir maintenant
trois films pour les trois prochains
soirs et puis à d'autres personnes
on va leur demander de choisir les trois
films et un pour ce soir ils vont
revenir demain en choisir un pour demain
soir et ils vont revenir après demain en
choisir un pour après demain soir
qu'est-ce qui se passe si je prends
maintenant les trois films pour trois
soirs bien je vais ce soir me détendre
parce que j'ai eu une journée difficile
je vais donc prendre un film vis et
demain je vais bien vouloir faire
l'effort vous voyez ce qui se passe si
je reviens chaque jour choisir un film
vous avez compris je vais prendre que
des films vi alors ce bien ça s'appelle
le biais du temps présent et face à ce
biais du temps présent
il va venir gêner un certain nombre de
nos décisions et de manière pour
certaines assez importante est assez
dramatique prenons la retraite par
exemple dans cette salle qui épargne
pour sa retraite
je vois pas beaucoup de mains qui se
lèvent alors rassurez vous j'ai posé la
question à une vingtaine de banques y
est ils sont deux seulement à avoir levé
la main pourtant les banquiers sont
censés être au courant qu'il faut
épargner pour leur retraite
c'est ce bien du temps présent il va
venir gêner l'effort de retraite en gros
vous n'avez pas en vue d'épargner
maintenant est de faire l'effort
maintenant pour en toucher les fruits
dans 40 ans ou dans 20 ans ou dans 30
ans en fonction de votre âge
donc comment on peut lutter contre ce
biais pour faire en sorte que les gens
épargnent bas aux etats-unis ils ont
monté ce qui s'appelle le smart plan
réseaux proposés à des salariés d'une
entreprise de décider maintenant
aujourd'hui d'épargné dans un an
et là tout d'un coup on nous demande
plus d'efforts on me demande de faire un
effort de main les vous l'avez vu avec
les films demain je veux bien faire un
effort
80 % des gens à qui on propose ça rentre
dans le plan d'epargne en retraite au
bout de trois ans ils sont encore 80% à
y être resté parce qu'on les force pas à
rester ils peuvent partir à tout moment
et le taux dépargne de ces gens là est
passée de 3,5 à 11 5%
on ose à peine imaginer la hausse et la
rémunération du taux dépargne qu'il
faudrait avoir pour avoir les mêmes
effets sur le taux d'épargné au niveau
des gens alors le nudge vous le voyez il
a tout de suite un grand intérêt alors
les premiers à s'être intéressé à cette
logique nages
ça va être les gouvernements américains
d'abord avec barack obama et anglais
ensuite avec david cameron qui vont
créer des notes unit pour améliorer
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
et puis évidemment les entreprises vont
s'y intéresser
pour essayer d'aider leurs clients et
leurs consommateurs à avoir des
expériences qu'ils soient meilleurs et à
avoir une vie plus saine et même parfois
les entreprises vont s'y intéresser pour
leurs propres salariés pour améliorer le
bien-être et pour accompagner le
changement à l'intérieur des entreprises
vous avez ici un exemple qui est utilisé
par l'industrie pharmaceutique comment
est-ce qu'on va aider les gens à
observer leur traitement thérapeutique
puisqu'il ya des vrais problèmes
d'observance qui viennent gêner
l'efficacité des médicaments
comment je vais aider les individus à
consommer mieux comment je vais
faciliter la vie de mes clients dans un
centre commercial et créer une
expérience client qui soit mémorable
comment je vais passer au digital
comment je vais faire en sorte que la
relation entre
clients et mois soit une relation
digital qu'ils soient plus simple pour
l'ensemble des personnes et pour finir
comment je vais accompagner la
transformation à l'intérieur d'une
entreprise et améliorer le bien-être de
mes salariés tous ces changements
en fait peuvent être aidés par le nudge
alors pour conclure j'ai envie de dire
qu'en france au pays de descartes 1 et
de la raison quand on a envie de changer
les comportements la première chose
qu'on a en tête c'est de faire une loi
ou de mettre en place des taxes ou
éventuellement si on n'a pas les moyens
de faire des lois de mettre en place des
taxes de faire des grandes campagnes de
communication qui vont effectivement
changer les choses et il faut continuer
à faire tout ça c'est très utile
seulement on voit bien que parfois ça
crée de manière très importante une
motivation mais que cette motivation
n'est pas suffisante pour faire passer à
l'acte et pour passer vos comportements
alors quand vous êtes dans une impasse
comme ça où les lois les taxes ou même
encore les grandes campagnes de
communication n'arrive pas à générer les
comportements qui sont souhaitables et
bat penser aux nages qui finalement va
être une solution simple à mettre en
oeuvre rapide et qui va être efficace
par rapport à l'objectif souhaité merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]